and they are defending their homeland
with resolve grit and ingenuity with the
united states at the helm 50 supportive
countries called the contact group came
together for the third time coordinating
weapons donations training and
replacement parts to arm ukraine they're
fighting for the very life of their
country
so your ability to endure suffering your
ability to endure casualties is directly
proportional to the object to be
attained
russia released images wednesday of
cruise missiles being fired at ukraine
after the country refused to surrender
sever donesk about 80 percent of that
city has been seized by russian forces
but the industrial zone including the
chemical plant where civilians and
soldiers are sheltering remains under
ukrainian control
russia however is determined to take the
eastern region of the country known as
the dawn bass
the person who wants to capture
everything will never stop after
capturing just a part of what he wants
in addressing the czech parliament
vladimir zelensky pleaded for a seventh
round of sanctions against russia as his
country awaits delivery of more heavy
and long-range weapons
by the end of the month shipments from
canada and other allied nations will
include more howitzer m triple sevens
plus high mobility artillery rocket
systems which users are being certified
on when you're in the fight you can
never get a get enough and you can never
get it quick enough in the meantime
ukrainians kiss and hug goodbye
hoping vulnerable loved ones in the east
can be taken to safety
crystal gamansen global news
london